now the mother whose children and
brother were killed in the crash
speaking to eight news now erlinda
zakaria says there are no words to
describe her pain and suffering
sally jaramillo is live at cheyenne in
commerce where memorial is growing for
the family sally
kirsten herlinda zacaria says her
children and her brother were her world
all of them with big hopes and
aspirations
erlinda zacarias is the mother of four
fernando joshua mejia h5 adrian
zacharias ten yuvia dailen zakarias
thirteen brian axel zacarias fifteen and
stepmother to two gabriel mejia varrera
23 david barrera 25 and her brother jose
sacarias caldera 35 years old she says
at the time of the crash they were on
their way home from the park she had
gone to work and was scheduled to meet
to have dinner never did she think her
life would change on saturday this
horrific crash only a few blocks from
home i see everything blocking i waited
until they told me
it was an accident they was
there all
says the four children were students at
lincoln elementary jim bridger middle
school and rancho high school
back out live sacarillas wants to thank
the community for all the love and
support she wants to reach her gofundme
as she hopes to send her stub children
to mexico to be buried as they two have
families there if you would like to help
the family visit our website
8newsnow.com for now reporting live in
north las vegas sally jaramillo live
local now
they